and he said Oh conservatism isn't dead
it's just intellectually boring and I
thought well yeah liberalism is - I have
Nick Gillespie with reason TV and today
we're talking to sam Tanenhaus the
editor of The New York Times Book Review
the Week in Review and the author of the
death of conservativism Sam thanks for
talking - hey Nick glad to be here with
you
conservativism is dead no I feel it
right actually I don't think it's dead
the the title actually now it's true the
New Republic story I wrote was given the
headline conservatism is dead I'm sorry
but your book is called death of
conservatism which is a little different
it's not declarative okay it's a
proposition okay and the proposition
would be that this is the moment for
conservative intellectuals I don't worry
so much about the politicians and the
parties parties find talented leaders
and they're able to rally the groups
they become Tribune's of a movement but
what movement will they be Tribune's
bill buckley whose biography I'm writing
once told me that Goldwater and Reagan
came to me he said because I asked him
how did you find them and he said no
they found me and what he meant was he
had the ideas he had the vocabulary and
that's what they needed and you know I'm
a kind of a literary person as you are
and and I think of politics being in
large part about the words we use and
the way we use them the way we conduct a
debate and a discussion and what
conservatism is lost it seems to me the
hard core conservatism the polarize of
partisan conservatism is the capacity to
elevate the argument the genius of
Buckley was that he made liberals think
and write better yeah you write in your
book commentary National Review the
Weekly Standard our mouthpieces of the
Republican Party at its most revanchist
what it and so are you saying that the
conservative thinkers not Republican
Party operatives but conservative
thinkers have drained the debate on
their side of any serious engagement of
ideas well I think to a large extent
they have
now it's not to say every single one of
them has and that one will never see an
interesting argument on them on the
right you know you do it in your
magazine George will does it every now
and we don't actually Irina will get to
libertarianism but I'm not sure that
that's it's part of the right anymore
well that's that's that's another
question whether it is that may be a
reflection of where things have gone in
the Buckley Day you know there was
always some room for but there was the
kind of libertarian now that you know
there were there were questions about
that and Whittaker Chambers was the guy
you know he sick Don hundred was not a
libertarian and Buckley called one of
his books are subtitled at reflections
of the libertarian journalists but then
also made sure to write out certain
people such as Ram yeah well well and
that was really had to do with religion
you know Buckley was you know very
devout Catholic and and didn't like
atheists he had a fight with max Eastman
about that in the early sixties but I
think what's happened is that
conservatives don't seem as interested
in speaking to the broader audience as
they once did there's a wonderful or
maybe sad irony in this one reason
Buckley started National Review was
because he's very gifted men like
himself James Burnham Whitaker chambers
were having trouble getting their stuff
published in the mainstream press every
now and again they would but for the
most part they couldn't they needed
their own magazine now what we see are
magazines and journalists who aren't
especially interested in reaching beyond
the course to reaching outside they are
there to hold up their end of the debate
and to support their candidates I think
a really striking example of this was
when William Kristol wrote a column for
the op-ed page of the New York Times my
employer and in effect made that column
a kind of clearinghouse for the McCain
and then Sarah Palin campaign what do
you what do you say to people who note
that at the what's what's at the top of
the Times bestseller list for nonfiction
is it Michelle Malkin or Mark Levin or
are there write glam factor right there
I mean absolutely partisan ideological
people
and there they've got the best-selling
books in the country so does that mean
they're only preaching to the choir or
are they actually engaging people in
debate that you may not find fully
comfortable well that's a good question
we don't know here I am editing the New
York Times Book Review and I can't tell
you who's buying books on the bestseller
list because it's done by the polling
division of the newspaper but they on
the strength of the audience's they have
the platforms they have on radio and
television if they are selling only to
their own they will dominate our
bestseller list for many years to come
it doesn't take them any copies together
I don't say that to denigrate the work
it's just that the bestseller list isn't
an indication of breadth or depth in an
argument if you could you have as easily
written a book called the death of
liberalism because who are the the
eggheads or the visionaries on the left
side of the debate I mean what you know
for every Glenn Beck there's a Rachel
Maddow or a Keith Olbermann who is
certainly not going to be putting
Einstein out of memory or out of
business any time soon is it just that
American political discourse is really
hackneyed now well you know yet the
answer is yes I could have written that
book and I've thought about it and maybe
would make a companion piece to this one
but we all need projects well you know
there was an interesting comment on this
book the death of conservatism I'm David
from websites a new majority comp by
Austin Bramwell figure you probably know
interesting young guy and he said no
conservatism isn't dead it's just
intellectually boring and I thought well
yeah liberalism is - the reason it
seemed worth writing about conservatism
is first of all I've been studying it
for twenty years since I started writing
biography of Whittaker Chambers in 1989
and also because conservatism has been
the dominant politics of the last era
and so it seemed better to look at it
and see where it had gone now it may be
a generation from now will look at
liberalism and see it eclipsed just the
way that's why I seemed important to me
in the book I wrote to describe how
liberalism failed what how much of the
death of conservativism are
or both you know hopes for that as well
as fears about that depending on where
you fall in the ideological spectrum is
really a short-term fluctuation and
electoral outcomes because in 2005
everybody including liberals we're
talking about we have to get used to the
permanent Republican majority and then
suddenly by 2006 that was all gone and
now it's the Republicans will never win
an election again right I think there's
too much emphasis on election outcomes
and I mention this in the book
now you could you can put in a different
way and I think it's plausible to say
the conservative movement really was
largely finished off in 1992 Democrats
have won pluralities and four out of the
last five elections presidential
elections the only one they won 2004 was
in the middle of a war it was the
closest reelection
in in a century and I was three
percentage points presented to something
larger
so electoral outcomes are tricky and one
other point I'd add for those who are
looking at the 2010 election and saying
well substantial Republican gains mean
the end of Obama style liberalism well
in 1938 the Republicans made huge gains
in the House of Representatives as what
seemed a repudiation of Franklin
Roosevelt it did not end New Deal
liberalism so I think it's less about
elections than it is about ideas and the
question now is are the dominant ideas
the big debates say over something like
health care really occurring within one
party now there's a theory of politics I
cite in the book
Samuel o bells solar system of politics
which says what seems to be an equal
two-party system is really an
alternating system of one-party rule and
so the question is have we now begun a
cycle of democratic rule I would like
conservatives to consider that
possibility and think what they might
have to do to stop it that's why I wrote
a book about the rise of conservatism at
a period when it seemed to be finished
we've been talking with sam Tanenhaus
the author of the death of
conservativism for Reason TV I'm Nikolas
peak
you